[Music]
if you had any doubts that Audrey would
turn out to be evil in descendants three
we're about to put them to rest she is
officially the queen of mean more
sparkles here's everything we know so
far the descendants three dolls were
just released the release of one doll in
particular has got everyone talking
we're talking about the Audrey doll of
course the song the new Audrey doll
sings is called the queen of mean and it
has revealed so much about her role in
the upcoming Disney Channel original
movie for starters it looks like Audrey
is getting her own solo in the three
quills and it's not a nice little
lullaby she's singing to get the
subjects of auradon to sleep she
officially proclaims herself as the
queen of mean that's not good you guys
let's explore this a bit further fans
knew that something was up with Audrey
from the d3 trailers she transformed
from a sweet pastel pink princess to a
punky crown and scepter stealing
villains but was she under some kind of
spell Vance had many theories about
Audrey's new look some thought that
Hades was involved if you look at the
mystery trailer Hades is looming over a
sleeping Audrey with his glowing blue
ember so did Audrey fall victim did a
big sweep spout sleeping scopes or was
she the one responsible for the big
sleep spells if she was sleeping -
chances are she had nothing to do with
the sleep spell but if Audrey's
grandmother made a deal with Hades to
wake her maybe it didn't go as planned
maybe the spell that Hades cast on
Audrey with his ember had some evil side
effects could Audrey be under hati spell
if so maybe that's what turned her into
the queen of means but let's be real
Audrey has always been mean ever since
the first descendants movie
she was a total mean girl when she was
picking on mouth for being a villain kid
she even got Jean to join in on the
bullying so maybe Audrey isn't under
Hades spell after all maybe her true
evil is finally being revealed in
descendant 3 and here's another
important clue if you look on the back
of the Audrey doll box it reads it's
finally Audrey's turn you're her sing
about her newfound badness
since Audrey had always harbored
resentment in her heart against mal we
would argue that her badness is nothing
new it has been building for a while and
from that card at the end of the threat
to auradon trailer it's highly likely
that Audrey wants to be like mal dr.
facili ace tarot cards show people what
they want to be if Audrey is jealous of
mal it stands to reason that she wants
to be like her and in her twisted
version of reality
mal is as bad as they come so audrey has
clearly decided to embrace her evil side
so she can feel powerful and in control
of her destiny let's explore the lyrics
of Audrey's song here's how we
interpreted them she seems that she will
show them what she means now that she's
bad then she sings that she'll be the
ruler of the dark and the bad cuz the
Devils show us what the Angels used to
be then the lyrics take an intriguing
turn when Audrey sings about someone
calling her the queen of mean and she
follows it up with the lyric that she
wants what she deserves
okay who is she referring to when she
sings he's calling me the queen of me we
have a pretty good idea we know from the
d3 official trailer that Ben proposes to
mal which totally messes with Audrey's
head
if Audrey tries to stop the engagement
then Ben would probably call Audrey the
queen of mean that would definitely
break Audrey's heart so maybe she's just
giving Ben what he wants by turning into
a villain and what does she mean when
she sings that she wants what she
deserves
it's more than just to be Ben's
girlfriend you guys she wants to be the
queen of Oregon and then probably tells
her that the only queen she'll ever be
is the queen of mean ouch that's enough
to send anybody into a scepter and Crown
stealing rage now let's talk about
Audrey's new look from her outfit and
hair it appears as though she stepped
off the aisle even though she has always
been an Oregon girl so she is totally
stealing the distressed leather and late
look directly from Mallon her friends
also Audrey's hair went from blonde with
pastel pink highlights to hot pink with
purple underneath what's particularly
interesting is the dragon necklace she's
wearing that's got to be a tribute to
Maleficent in her dragon form it makes
sense because she's wielding Maleficent
scepter this new Audrey doll is loaded
with hints about the future of Audrey
and auradon she receives a full-on
villain kid makeover she's got a stolen
crown on her head
and she's totally up to no good with
Maleficent scepter her new song the
Queen Amin reveals the truth about
Audrey's story in descendants three
she's going to cause a lot of trouble
for mal Ben and their crew getting
dumped humiliated and rejected is
basically the recipe to villain hood if
you think about it Maleficent had her
heart broken by a prince - Audrey is the
perfect person to carry out evil deeds
with Maleficent scepter you might even
say that she is acting on Maleficent's
behalf and on behalf of every
heartbroken villain on the Isle what do
you guys think of the new Audrey doll
sound off in the comments be sure to
subscribe to the things channel to be
the first to see our latest videos on
all things descendants 3 and hit that
thumbs up button while you're at it
thanks for watching
[Music]